you know I've come to a realization guys
if you don't have ethics you have to be
unbelievably dumb to be broke
because ripping people off is so easy
it's so unbelievably simple and a lot of
people comment in this in my videos like
oh man I shouldn't be an engineer I
should be a scammer no of course not of
course I would never recommend that but
if you're a sociopath if you have no
morals I don't understand I don't
understand why you're not balling and
today we're going to talk about one of
the simple ways to achieve fast
financial freedom as a sociopath as an
insane person as a predator on poor
people and that is the Ponzi scheme the
good old-fashioned Bernie Madoff Bernie
Madoff with all your money you know like
a lot of you maybe I thought a few days
ago that how big of a deal is this until
I came across a Ponzi scheme so big that
this isn't even that video this is
preparing your eyeballs and your
earholes for what is to come because
you're not ready to hear what I have to
tell you so I have to set you up with a
worse Ponzi scheme like a lower-level
Ponzi scheme to get us to the place that
we could talk about this without your
eyes bleeding and you know and you going
deaf so the person the pons can were
talking about today the lower level one
to get you prepped up for the high level
stuff is trafficmonsoon
now I don't know if you guys have heard
of this it was sort of bigger back in
2014 but this guy Charles Scoville ran
it and who is Charles Scoville well
luckily he put out a video who is
Charles Scoville scam where he
introduces himself I wanted to make a
video so that you can see a little bit
more about who I really am as a person
because I know there's a lot of people
out there who will tell you that you
can't do something this guy is a
sleazeball in a 240p webcam and this guy
this guy that you're seeing right here
you know he's a little bit charismatic
but he wouldn't you wouldn't normally
think of this guy as the guy who's gonna
rip everyone off but this guy is the
perpetrator of the traffic monsoon put
that in your brain I had a lot of people
tell me that I couldn't do it that I
wouldn't be successful at it but I
should give up that I shouldn't even try
but deep down inside was a desire
burning harder and and and hotter than
anything that is that was telling me at
the time that I couldn't do something
burning desire that's all you need
Charles Scoville so he started this
thing called traffic monsoon and to make
a long story short it was this scheme
where you purchased these things called
ad packs and I don't want to get into
exactly what an ad pack was because
there's a little bit convoluted but
basically you bought in for $50 and in
about like 60 to 100 days you made $55
that was the premise right and if that
doesn't make a lot of sense don't worry
it didn't make a lot of sense the idea
though was that they were you were
basically gonna click on several ads a
day on their website and by clicking on
those ads you shared in the profit
margins of the company and so then
basically the business model was selling
ads or so they said now the reason there
should have been red flags is because
it's like turning money into more money
with no risk how is that ever gonna
happen it never happens what investors
didn't know is the company was basically
making nothing off of actual advertising
and what they were making all their
money off of was selling the quote ad
packs to would-be investors who thought
they were gonna make fifty five bucks
off of 50 bucks you know in a short
amount of time and so they would pay off
people who were earning money with
people who were buying into the new
product classic Ponzi scheme right rob
Peter to pay Paul and that's not the
impressive part because when you see
this guy
[Music]
how much money do you think he's I want
you guys to write in the comments below
how much money you think was gotten out
of this little scheme right because I
would always think a few hundred
thousand there's no way he gets more
than a few hundred thousand but then I
see this event online you know this
happened in October 2015 is the one-year
anniversary
[Music]
and this thing is like packed it's like
this packed auditorium and there's these
like sketchy signs that literally in
Scrabble letters say make money online
that scream they're screaming at the top
of their lungs if an image could screech
this would be the image and it would
screech this is a scam make money online
in Scrabble letters oh that's a scam and
you have of course the guy pointing at
the thing do you have computer and Wi-Fi
you can make money but the thing is the
thing is packed the place is packed and
this is our first indication that maybe
this unassuming guy's making more money
than we thought
traffic monsoon deep down inside was a
desire burning hotter than anything that
is that was telling me at the time that
I couldn't do something and it makes
sense because early on people were
really making money when people were
joining it joining it joining it so I
want you guys to put your final answer
for how much money this scheme made down
below right now I I want to know how
much you think a Ponzi scheme from this
guy right here could make now are you
ready to be wrong this Ponzi scheme
according to the SEC since October 2014
going through 2016 in two years or three
years made two hundred and seven million
dollars let me repeat that because I
don't think you heard me
traffic monsoon made two hundred and
seven million dollars the first sign
that things were falling apart was
PayPal froze his accounts and he decided
oh I'm super excited to announce that
I'm starting my own bank because it was
the only Bank they would accept him
because everyone realized he was a Ponzi
scheme until the SEC came in and they
froze his accounts and basically he's
he's been caught at this point but I
want you to think about this because
okay he's been caught he probably hid
money Offshore's or whatever I'm sure
I'm sure the guy has money stashed
somewhere but I want to give you a
thought experiment what would happen if
someone did it better
what would happen if someone was more
clever more slick
had a smoother operation a better pitch
than this garbage what would happen if
it was done right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and don't forget to smash like and
subscribe thank you
[Music]
[Music]
Sakura
[Music]